[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction sur
tv fils voici les titres en images de ce
13 avril à 2017 la ligne 18 du futur
métro du grand paris express qui reliera
versailles à l'aéroport d'orly a été
déclarée d'utilité publique nous verrons
ce que cela va changer longue de 35 km
elle desservira a dans un premier temps
cette gare dès 2024
inauguré en 1996 dans le quartier 50 ans
à montigny le bretonneux le
conservatoire des arts célèbre 20 ans
d'existence tout au long de cette saison
nous revenons sur l'histoire de cet
équipement ou 17 disciplines sont
enseignées et puis au zoo de thoiry
l'espace dinosaures 2 innove et propose
une expérience unique un voyage en
réalité virtuelle dans la vallée des
dinosaures une animation qui rejoint les
seize dinosaures robot reproduit dans le
respect des mensurations originel nous
verrons ça tout à l'heure et dans
l'actualité blinoise aujourd'hui la
remise en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire d'un jeune homme de 21 ans
interpellé en début de semaine après
l'agression d'un inspecteur du permis de
conduire à vélizy il a reconnu les faits
mais conteste avoir porté des coups il
dit avoir voulu contester la décision de
son examinateur le tribunal
correctionnel de versailles a renvoyé l
affaire au 17 mai prochain elle les
inspecteurs du permis de conduire avait
lancé lundi en début de semaine un
mouvement de grève pour dénoncer leurs
difficiles conditions de travail
et puis une autre profession en colère
également vient d'apprendre que la cgt a
déposé plusieurs préavis de grève
couvrant la période de distribution des
plis électoraux le syndicat affirme que
la poste a empoché plus de 70 millions
d'euros de l'état pour cette mission
sans que les salariés soient
suffisamment payé pour accomplir cette
tâche supplémentaire
nous allons maintenant évoquer le
dossier du grand paris c'était le
dernier
rançon du projet du grand paris express
à ne pas l'être encore la ligne 18 qui
passe notamment par saint quentin en
yvelines a été déclarée d'utilité
publique il ya une dizaine de jours le
tracé de 35 km est donc entérinée au
sein de l'agglomération il y a les
satisfaits et les mécontents comme
souvent nous en parlons avec nicolas qui
a levé dimanche soir nicolas bonsoir en
effet dans le camp des satisfaits
wilfried on retrouve la ville de
guyancourt plus que c'est sur l'ancien
site de tell est ce que la future gare
de l'agglomération sera construite et ça
c'est forcément bon pour l'attractivité
de la ville
parmi les heureux il y à aussi voisins
le bretonneux le métro ne passera pas
sous le quartier de la bretonnière ce
qui était un temps envisagé le tracé
alternatif avec un passage sous le golf
national a finalement été retenue en
revanche dans le camp des déçus il y à
la commune de magny les hameaux qui a
déposé un recours contre cette
déclaration d'utilité publique auprès du
conseil d'état
ce n'est pas la seule commune il y en a
plusieurs notamment dans l'essonne qui
s'insurgent depuis de nombreuses années
contre le passage en aérien qui est
prévue sur territoire oui pour ces
villes elles sont cinq au total et des
collectifs aussi de riverains le passage
en viaduc prévu sera trop bruyant
mauvais également pour l'environnement
écoutez à ce propos le maire de magny
les hameaux
on va se retrouver avec une technologie
qui fait du tout nouvel qui est pas du
tout durable qui est pas du tout
innovantes
c'est tout simplement la technologie des
années 80-90 du métro qui la ligne 14 du
fameux projet météores qu'est-ce qui a
d'innovant là dedans rien on va avoir un
transport qui sera mise en pour les
populations locales pour les populations
rurales notamment qui sont sacrifiés
l'estiment et puis qui apportera
peut-être pas forcément
ce qui était de base dans ce projet qui
était de pouvoir se déplacer vite ce
recours administratif ne devrait pas en
tout cas chamboulé dans les grandes
lignes le projet de la ligne 18 un
projet important pour le territoire et
les autorités puisque il desservira le
campus paris saclay appelé à devenir le
silicon valley à la française
et pour rappel la ligne 18 c'est un
premier tronçon entre l'aéroport d'orly
et le plateau de saclay en 2024
puis jusqu'à la gare de versailles
chantiers en 2030 coûts du projet et
total 2 7 milliards d'euros
sans le matériel roulant merci nicolas
nous poursuivons ce journal avec un tout
autre sujet nous allons voyager dans le
temps les dinosaures sont de retour à
thoiry le parc installé
seize animatronics de taille réelle dans
un espace dédié et il ya une nouveauté
est cette année pour la deuxième édition
c'est une expérience de réalité
virtuelle nous en parlions en titre elle
les visiteurs sont téléportés 125
millions d'années en arrière
parmi les dinosaures camille lambert a
testé l'expérience
[Musique]
il pourrait vous tuer d'un coup de tête
mais n'ayez crainte le pashi ses fans
aux eaux russes est herbivore
c'est plutôt du t-rex que vous devriez
avoir peur c'est l'un des plus
redoutables carnivores terrestres dans
un parcours le parc de thoiry emmène ses
visiteurs au temps des dinosaures
évidemment à ces dinosaures bouge remue
crash de l'eau comme derrière nos éructe
font du bruit tout ça pour le bonheur
des petits et des plus grands
c'est un peu des stars les dinosaures et
puis ça à leur place dans un zoo après
tout puisque nous sommes là pour montrer
le vivant tout le vivant le nid vivants
animés tels qu'ils étaient à toutes les
époques
une exposition version 2 qui compte
quelques nouveautés les apprentis
paléontologues peuvent maintenant
s'exercer sur le camp de fouilles et les
plus aventuriers plonge au coeur du
crétacé grâce à un procédé de réalité
virtuelle
on voit une sorte de ptérodactyle on
voit un dinosaure avec un bec de
perroquet tout le monde croit que les
t-rex c'est un des principal dinosaures
sauf qu'il ya eu des dinosaures
aventurex et ça parle de ces dinosaures
comme ça là on est dedans c'est à dire
qu'on se tourne à 360 degrés en
regardant bas en haut et on voit des
dinosaures partout et on va pas se
polluer la fin mais c'est vrai que
on vit le truc à fond et pour les
enfants c'est génial et pour les adultes
aussi donc c'est parfait
créé par la société anime à tours cette
attraction est accessible au tarif de 5
euros
les visiteurs ont jusqu'à fin septembre
pour profiter des différentes
installations
peut-être les dinosaures se
laisseront-ils charisme
[Musique]
et on va parler maintenant parler d'un
anniversaire celui du conservatoire des
arts à montigny le bretonneux il fête
cette année ses 20 ans le conservatoire
assez près de 600 personnes qui le font
vivre tout au quotidien nous avons
rencontré elle est responsable de sa
structure et plusieurs personnes aussi
qui viennent y participer chaque jour
regardez ce reportage de mélanie poquet
le conservatoire à nikki entre depuis
vingt ans au moins un cours par semaine
de la peinture de la poterie plus un
retour à ses premiers amours
c'est rare que je m'en tape fort il faut
vraiment qu'ils et aux empêchements
pourquoi pour que le loop cours j'ai pas
trop réalisé que ça faisait vingt ans
nettement
c'est vrai que oui on dit toujours que
ça passe vite mais c'est la vérité du
fait d'avoir fait ou quand même
différent puis tous les tous les ans en
fait on a d'autres sujets de ces jamais
ennuyeux on a toujours c'est toujours
très agréable de pouvoir faire
des nouvelles choses annick fait partie
des 580 élèves du conservatoire
municipal de cette saison 2010 sept des
huit disciplines y sont proposés des
disciplines qui change avec le temps
déjà il a 20 ans donc il a 20 ans je
crois que c'est significatif de tout
l'attachement que porte la population à
ce conservatoire
quand on vit comme ça par une vingtaine
d'années et qu'on évolue et qu'on suit
un peu les mouvements artistiques aussi
c'est important au niveau des cours qui
sont mises en place etc
je crois que l'important c'est
primordial au niveau de cette commune on
a plus de 500 élèves un conservatoire
est donc un lieu d'enseignement destinés
à tous et dans un cadre de loisirs mais
qui peut devenir petit à petit un petit
peu plus que du loisir pour ceux qui le
souhaitent donc forcément on va
accueillir des publics qui vont être
débutant des enfants et on va chercher à
les accompagner tout au long de leur
démarche artistique et répondent
vraiment à des questions qui vont être
de plus en plus pointues alors
contrairement au conservatoire de
musique nous passerons pas de diplôme
enfin pour passer d'une année sur
l'autre
les tarifs débutent aux alentours de 110
euros pour une heure d'enseignement par
semaine
c'est ce professeur anime
quotidiennement les cours proposés
séverine enseigne la poterie la
céramique depuis sept ans j'ai cherché à
donner des cours mais qui ne soient pas
des cours dans un atelier
voilà c'est à dire qu'ici on a un public
qui recherche
des choses plus spécifiques qu'un
atelier où chacun arrive avec ses
projets donc on travaille sur des thèmes
et des techniques
près de 40 % des élèves sont des enfants
les plus jeunes ont 5 ans savait ce que
je pensais que cg j'ai fait un quart de
la vie qui met du coup faire maintenant
après avoir investi la gare saint-lazare
l'an dernier pour une première édition
la nuit de l'électro s'installe au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ce sera le 4 juin une dizaine
d'artistes sont prévues accompagné par
une scénographie inédite pendant que
vous voyez les images de la précédente
édition à paris c'est un lieu insolite
pour les amateurs de techno l'événement
va débuter à 15 heures et se terminera
le lendemain à 10h et c'est un jour
férié
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà réserver vos
places le rendez-vous est interdite aux
mineurs
et puisque l'on parle culture dans un
autre registre c'est aujourd'hui que
s'ouvre le troisième mondial de l'impro
junior et cet attrape l'événement est
organisé par la compagnie déclic théâtre
avec elle les fédérations et
associations belges suisses et
québécoises correspondant aux quatre
pays participants les matchs se
déroulent à l'école de musique et de
danse et à la merise les deux premiers
mondiaux ont été remportées par le
québec et nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
les résultats de cette édition dans
notre prochaine édition
vous avez un meuble ancien qui ne vous
convient plus qui ne convient plus à la
décoration actuelle de votre intérieur
la chouette échoppes peut peut-être le
remettre au goût du jour l'établissement
est installé à saint cyr l'école
la créatrice amélie restaure et
personnalise les vieux meubles camille
lambert semaine c'était une armoire à
pharmacie typique
des années 40 50 60
j'ai vraiment des caps et jusqu'au bois
ensuite sous couche et puis trois
couches de peinture à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur
donner une nouvelle jeunesse à des
meubles anciens amélie en a fait sa
spécialité réparer poncet et peindre une
passion depuis 15 ans l'origine a été
par ma passion pour la décoration et mes
faibles moyens d'étudier coûte donc pour
combiner les deux je me suis mise à
récupérer des meubles et à essayer de
les refaire pour moi ça fait quelques
années que le vintage le rétro remis au
goût du jour est à la mode
j'ai l'impression vraiment que ça
s'inscrit dans la durée installés depuis
décembre à saint cyr l'école elle a
lancé son site internet la chouette
échoppes restauration terminée ou à
venir mais aussi des créations
amélie réalise ses propres bijoux ça
c'est mes boîtes de perles lancou jeu
on stocke toutes les perles que je
trouve dans les brocantes chez emmaüs
le petit truc en plus ça permet de
changer et
et ça s'intègre bien dans la démarche
également rajeunir des pièces tout en
préservant leur authenticité une
démarche artistique et éco responsable
les particuliers peuvent aussi lui
demander un devis pour réactualiser
leurs meubles 100% alors les beaux jours
sont donc revenus c'est le moment de
reprendre du service au jardin et quels
sont les plantations à privilégier à
cette période de l année pour terminer
ce journal direction magny les hameaux
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines les rayons du
soleil amène la douceur printanière
abeilles bourgeon première fleur le
jardin se réveille et pour lui redonner
des couleurs après l'hiver c'est le
moment de planter selon ses envies
ça peut être encore des bruyères ça peut
être ça peut être décès d'hommes ça peut
être des hellébores des fois il faut il
faut se laisser convaincre par une fleur
sans problème et puis et puis il a
collectionné dans son jardin
[Musique]
du rose du blanc ou du jaune comme un
peintre qui crée sa toile sans oublier
l'importance de protéger les nouvelles
venues et maintenant ce qui va être
intéressant c'est de venir recouvrir
notre terre par du copo qui va permettre
de d'éviter la levée des mauvaises
herbes parce qu'on est presque lave de
son jardin et puis de conserver
l'humidité au sol donc les végétaux en
une croissance encore plus importante et
plus rapide
un jardin prête à accueillir les amis et
les chasses aux oeufs à venir mais
surtout une dose de positif selon une
étude britannique
jardiner au moins 30 minutes par semaine
serait bon pour le moral et pour
terminer ce journal n'oubliez pas que
dès mardi vous avez rendez vous avec une
édition spéciale consacrée au premier
tour delà du débat des présidentielles à
partir de 21h sur tv fils très bon week
end
[Musique]